not all fossil fuels are the same
and this is because different kinds of
organic material were heated and
compressed in different ways creating
different kinds of fossil fuels
one of these kinds of fossil fuels is
petroleum the word petroleum comes from
the latin word for rock petra and the
latin word for oil oleum
this makes sense because it's an oily
substance that's found in reservoirs
trapped in rock humans have been using
oil for a very long time
early civilizations found it bubbling up
from the ground at natural wells the oil
they saw coming straight out of the
earth is called crude oil or crude
petroleum which means that it is
unrefined and unprocessed crude oil was
probably one of the ingredients in greek
fire which was a flame throwing weapon
that the byzantines would fling at their
enemies today we refined crude oil into
many products like gasoline and diesel
for vehicles kerosene for heating and
asphalt for road construction
it's also used to make plastics and
synthetic fabrics
another type of fossil fuel is coal
which we mostly burn to make electricity
but it can also be used for heating and
cooking
it's a solid shiny black flammable rock
which is mostly formed from the carbon
remains of fossilized plants like moss
over thousands of years plant material
transforms into a carbon-rich compound
called peat
and then with some pressure it becomes
soft coal which is called lignite
and then with more pressure it becomes
bituminous coal
and then finally it becomes a hard coal
called anthracite
the longer the plant remains are put
under pressure the more energy dense it
becomes
so if you burned anthracite you would
get a lot more energy than if you burned
peat
burning coal releases carbon dioxide
sulfur dioxide nitrogen oxides and other
gases into the air
so coal is one of the dirtiest fossil
fuels
the cleanest burning fossil fuel is
natural gas meaning that it emits the
least amount of carbon dioxide or other
air plumes
this is not the same type of gas as we
put into our vehicles that type comes
from petroleum instead natural gas is
mostly used for generating electricity
heating homes and cooking food
your oven furnace water heater dryer or
grill all might run on natural gas
natural gas is a naturally occurring
mixture of gases
and it's mostly made up of methane
ethane propane and butane
the gas is colorless and odorless so
natural gas companies often add a rotten
egg smell to the fuel to make leaks
easier to detect
but even though we can't see or smell
natural gas humans have been detecting
it and using it for centuries
there is evidence that more than 2 000
years ago people in china created bamboo
pipelines to transport the gas so that
they could use it to boil salt water and
separate out the salt
and today we still use pipelines to
transport gas across land although
they're no longer made out of bamboo
another kind of non-renewable resource
is nuclear fuel
nuclear power plants don't burn fossil
fuels instead they split uranium through
something called nuclear fission
just one kilogram of uranium can produce
24 million kilowatt hours of energy
compare that with one kilogram of coal
which can produce eight kilowatt hours
of energy
in other words nuclear fission produces
a lot of energy
it also produces a lot of heat which we
mostly use to make electricity
also nuclear energy is known as a clean
energy because the only greenhouse gas
emission is water vapor which tends to
cycle out of the atmosphere faster than
other greenhouse gases
but the downside is the spent fuel is a
dangerous radioactive waste and
recycling the nuclear waste is dangerous
and expensive
petroleum coal natural gas and nuclear
fuel make up 85 percent of the world's
energy consumption but as our
populations and our energy needs grow
it's becoming more important to
integrate renewable resources the
sources that could be restored by
natural processes into our energy mix
here's something to think about what's
something that you do in your day that
uses energy
does that energy come from fossil fuels
and if so which one
understanding how you get your energy is
part of understanding what powers your
community your country and the world